I'm just having a [ __ ] mental
breakdown right now because I thought I
had left school days in the past I never
thought I'd hear those two words again
I'd be sitting next to the guy who Lucas
cuz I remember that mal phase and I
thought they must everyone must be
trolling yeah this is like the
interspecies reviewers kind of thing
everyone's giving this a ten everyone's
being [ __ ] ironic there's no way that
there can be a guy I'm sure there were
I'm sure there were but like I can't
imagine I couldn't imagine you all
ironically gave it a turn I just I just
remember like I had a video like this is
a you were you corrected your opinion no
not enough I mean two videos I had I had
a video the first video ever made on
school days was right after I finished
watching it and I think like a six year
old video and it's cold like is the
school days ending a masterpiece or
something like that oh my god there's
just like me going like yeah yeah okay
it's like it's like imagine if Code
Geass is ending right you had that but
then 25 episodes was just as fun
following like like Nunnally like just
yeah her daily life you know I mean like
that shit's boring I want [ __ ] seats
like it wasn't like okay the ending was
satisfying but it was just it was just a
boring show it was a boring show for
half of it and then the second half was
just like anger management I think I
gave us such a high score because I just
appreciated the meta behind how the
director and producer chose the little
worst ending of any visual novel in
existence it was like grade-a trolling
in my opinion and I think that's why I
said it was kind of Jean I mean it's
definitely different like that anything
was not like an ending like that we you
don't I said why we're still talking
about school days after [ __ ] how many
years of it's me now yeah but okay
here's the thing right is that sometimes
what what is a good ending right is it
is do it do you think it as a good
ending because if the story made sense
it really like in the whole thing it was
like wow that's a great ending it really
made sense all the characters built up
to this know it's a good ending because
the main character was [ __ ] awful and
everyone in that show was god-awful
yeah we just wanted to see them get like
revenge but like but I would argue that
like an ending that is good
right doesn't necessarily have to be
memorable all right there's a difference
between a memorable ending and a good
it's a memorable I mean it's just like
pure shock factor right it's just like
pure shock factor and it's got not much
substance behind that shot right right
right
and that was my big problem with school
days because at least with the visual
novel you could see [ __ ] sex scenes
for one just some tips he's getting 316
oh [ __ ] exactly cuz ELISA in that what
he actually makes made sense why he was
getting all this [ __ ] [ __ ] did it
did it made sense because he was a
[ __ ] hentai my visual what in the
anime because they didn't explain the
hentai subplot yeah
or the subtext I guess that it was like
a hint I I think that was the first time
as a teenager there that I was like Oh
sex again like really we're gonna go
with sex again all right geez that's
like the age where like you start to be
like beyond those kinds of like six and
poop jokes where it's all about like
like challenging my sixteen-year-old
atheist brain then it's not good
material you know I mean I'm pretty sure
I watched that like peepee poo-poo thing
that made me laugh on YouTube like two
weeks ago so I don't know like fully
gone but right but like it always goes
back right like you'll often prove
drunks at age ten not at age fifteen and
then you'll offer poop jokes again at
age twenty I being a teenager's [ __ ]
weird that's actionable I could say it
is [ __ ] whiff because teenagers we
horny as [ __ ] right yeah I guess when
you're a teenager you wanna this is
weird thing that you don't do as a
nate'll right when you're an adult you
fully accept what you're into as a
teenager you're like trying to mold your
interest into what you think yeah yeah
yeah I felt like the shows that you
watched which is probably why this guy
gave Mallett I have a [ __ ] school days
of Tani's like I want to be this smart
you can see through all the [ __ ] to
see that masterpiece I will fully admit
that's exactly right I'm not gonna sit
here and say like I did that too right
yeah I'm out there's a part of me that
would argue that Prison Break was a
masterpiece of our time right when I
look back now maybe the [ __ ] was like
thinking I was 15 yeah you know like
it's when you're a teen
you have dumb opinions you know why you
should never start an attitude channel
in your know known as your very highly
regretted